welcome to the second annual
international conference on climate
change we're delighted to be able to
demonstrate once again the breath and
the quality of the people who make up
the skeptics movement in the global
warming debate there are very few
statesman in the world today who have
the courage to stand up to global
warming alarmism it is especially
difficult to do this in Europe where
radical environmentalism has come to
play the role that was occupied by the
ideology of communism before the fall of
the Soviet Union so I am honored to be
able to introduce to you such a man this
evening please give a warm welcome to
President Vaclav Klaus
thank you thank you very thank you very
much I'm really happy to be here again
it is evident that the climate change
debate has not made any detectable
progress and that the much needed long
overdue exchange of views has not yet
started it seems to me that they tell us
quite persuasively that there is no one
unique unprecedented climate change just
now but permanent climate changes the
climate system of the our planet has a
significant internal variability and the
past data are in this respect quite
convincing second the current climate
changes cannot be subsumed under the
hypothesis of anthropogenic global
warming this claim is based exclusively
on the results of experiments is the
very imperfect computer models and
finally there is no fixed and stable
relationship between measure temperature
and co2 emissions the environmentalists
are at the same time technology
nihilists who freely and irresponsibly
operate these miraculous technologies
which have only one effect they have not
yet been invented this is this is an
apparent schizophrenia on their side
they should tell us how it really is I'm
afraid they are not so naive as they
pretend to be they probably only do not
want to
to reveal their true plans and ambitions
to stop economic development and return
mankind centuries back to conclude it is
evident that the environmentalists don't
want to change the climate they want to
change us and our behavior their
ambition is to control and manipulate us
therefore it shouldn't be surprising
that they recommend preventive not
adaptive policies adaptation would be a
voluntary behavior our voluntary
behavior which is not what they aim at
they do not want to recognize that to
quote Nigel Lawson the capacity to adopt
is arguably the most fundamental
characteristic of mankind and that our
adaptive capacity is increasing all the
time with the development of Technology
the alarm environmentalists speak about
saving the planet we have to ask from
what and from whom
one thing I know for sure they have to
say it end us from them thank you very
much